when I was at AGT we got the diagnosis
that you had lupus you were very upfront
about it I pulled you aside and I said
to you look you need to slow down you
got too many [__] jobs okay we say a
frenzy a frenzy yes and I said to Nick
and I'm not saying anything out of
school I said if you're not working
you're [__] you need to sleep the guy
either works or [__] there's no there's
no time to eat he doesn't sleep there's
no break 12 kids later healthy strong
10 more jobs we're here to be fruitful
multiplied that's the purpose of life
procreate Nick there is a rumor on the
internet that you are having all these
kids because you have Lupus and you've
got to find a Kidney donor in case the
[__] hits the fan did you read this did
you read it I read that yeah I've I've
heard that one I've heard even more like
science science fiction rumors of like
that I'm like hoarding organs but I can
just try to get the right one that's a
brilliant plan yeah yeah I don't know
how that those medical procedures would
work but I think I'm good my body's
functioning quite fine without the uh
without the help from my Offspring I
make no judgments that's the reason I
hired Fred anytime I need any kind of
organ that sounds like like a like a
villains or like origin story or like I
don't know like I that that sounds
ridiculous to me but I I'm having kids
because I love my kids by the way I
heard you say you had a bad vasectomy
consultation last year did you ever go
through with it are you are you did you
do it uh uh you know I was I was looking
around I was shopping to see you know it
any any I'm that that's a scary thing
man yeah absolutely and it's I felt
pressured I felt the world was was
trying to make me get a vasectomy I
don't look I don't operate well under
pressure my body my choice do you feel
the world wants you to get a vasectomy
that's an amazing thing yeah wow you
ever know what it's like to be like
walking down the street and just a
random stranger like man you need to go
get snipped I'm like I don't even know
foreign